ces dernières semaines vous êtes ralenti
devant la poste de Montini le Bretonneux
et pour cause l'avenue du centre est en
travaux sur cette portion un passage
piéton classique avec dci va sortir de
terre pour matérialiser la réduction de
vitesse aux automobilistes il n'y aura
donc pas de passerelle au-dessus de la
route cette nouvelle liaison piétonne
devrait permettre d'améliorer
l'accessibilité à la gare pour les
personnes venant du parc depuis le début
des travaux la circulation ne se fait
plus que sur une seule voie dans les
deux sens sur cette portion et les
ouvriers devraient être présents jusqu'à
mi-juillet tout cela pour un but et de
250000 € hors
taxe